one of the things I tell young men well
and young women as well but the young
men really need to hear this more I
think you should be a monster an
absolute monster and then you should
learn how to control it
so a man who's capable of aggression but
has it under control is a way more
useful man than one who cannot do that
and so you're willing to go get a job
but you're terrified of an interview
it's like there's a dragon for you
because you want to fight the dragons
that guard the gates of the treasure
that you wish to attain
the productivity requires aim
orientation responsibility discipline
that willingness to work that
willingness to make sacrifices which is
the Hallmark of maturity in the service
of a higher goal
it orients you solidly in the world if
you do that and it gives you a dragon to
fight
what do you want to grow up you want to
be illiterate
you want to be inarticulate
you're going to have to negotiate
you're gonna have to lead you're gonna
have to convince you're gonna have to
think to say to a 18 year old
you're okay the way you are that just
deflates them
[Music]
you know when you go to the gym and you
start lifting weights well your body's
going to transform but it's not going to
do that if you just sit around you have
to face your being with the necessity of
transformation and then all sorts of new
things that you had no idea you were
capable of will make themselves manifest
those are the dragons you know the ones
that stand in the path that leads to the
light and you have to say to yourself I
will
do good
nonetheless
everyone great makes that decision
make that decision because maybe you're
great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]